pas il y a depuis avant-hier nous en
parlions déjà hier six condamnés à mort
dans les prisons france six
condamnations à mort en six mois ce qui
repose bien sur le problème de la peine
de mort invité du crible de daniel
grandclément ce matin maître badinter
qui est lui partisan ou le savez de
l'abolition de la peine capitale à
maître badinter qui aussi va sans doute
plaider facile de cassation les dossiers
des quatre premiers condamnés à mort
vous êtes donc l'un des plus acharnées
défenseur de l'abolition de la peine de
mort vous sembliez finalement avoir
convaincu pas mal de gens il ya quelques
mois puis tout d'un coup on a
l'impression qu'on assiste un échec
complet de vos thèses pourquoi jeter le
le soir du verdict de la sphère patrick
henry les journalistes l'interrogeaient
me disait alors c'est fini la peine de
mort qu'on n'aura plus à mort et je
répondais en disant pas du tout
l'abolition est certaine mais avant que
l'abolition soit acquise il y aura
encore des condamnations à mort et
peut-être des exécutions mais là c'est
tout à fait étonnant le nombre de
contenants vous répondra de la même
façon ce n'est pas parce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui des condamnations à mort que
nous n'aurons pas - l'abolition demain
le vrai problème c'est pourquoi est-ce
qu'en ce moment depuis six mois nous
assistons à une cure sysmans évident de
la répression et je crois que ce préfet
s'il a expliqué entre le mois de mars de
l'année dernière et le mois de septembre
la période octobre la période à laquelle
commence c'est une vague
vous avez eu la discussion du projet
sécurité liberté et pendant des mois on
a expliqué aux français grand renfort
d'image sur la télévision nous rappeler
le petit bonhomme le petit délinquant
qui devenait énorme qu'ils étaient
constamment menacés dans leur sécurité
dans leur vie on leur a aussi expliqué
ce qu'était exactement cette loi ici en
particulier avec des gens qui n'étaient
pas pour cette fois oui dont moi mais je
ne parle pas là des dispositions de la
loi que j'ai combattu et je continuerai
à combattre je parle simplement de la
façon dont on l'a présenté
l'hymne amalgame qui est tout à fait
significatif et qui est tout à fait
détestable
pourquoi parce que si vous regardez les
chiffres de la criminalité tels qu'ils
sont et pas douteux qu en ce qui
concerne la moyenne délinquance
eh bien vous avez une augmentation et je
dirais que nous baignons règlement dans
une société dans lesquels la délinquance
est considérable là j'ai regardé les
chiffres avant de venir en 1979
nous avons atteint un million deux cent
dix mille vols sans violence 200 2000
vols d'automobiles par an 250 mille vols
de rugby vendredi
bref une une délinquance moyennes et
petites considérable alors cela crée
angoisse exaspération sentiment
d'insécurité mais si vous regardez la
zone de la grande criminalité sanglant
de profits c'est à dire celle qui est
directement concerné avec le problème de
la peine de mort
ce que l'on a jamais dit aux français
c'est que depuis 1977
en ce qui concerne les meurtres
crapuleux c'est à dire les plus odieux
ce à propos desquels on parle de peine
de mort comme menace dissuasive non
seulement ils n'ont pas augmenté les ont
diminué on est à tout petit toutes les
parties non mais moi aussi j'ai regardé
le même bus que vous d'ailleurs c'est à
dire apports de la grande criminalité en
france où là je m'aperçois que la grande
criminalité c'est à dire que les hold-up
le vol même armée vols avec violence
tous à augmenter en 62 78 79 + 9 % et
entreprendre tous les actes eux armés ou
avec armes et à chaque fois seulement t
on va passer vers une bataille de jambes
mais on se regardait j'aurais simplement
marquer contre 1977 le moment auquel a
été publié le rapport peyrefitte et 1979
le nombre les hold up que vous évoquez
et qui sont détestables et es15 180 il
est tombé à 12 131 oui vacances 1179 ça
remonte c'est vrai pour les rythmes et
de 69 ans va simplement que encore une
fois quand il s'agit de peines de mort
puisque c'est d'elle dont il est
question
il ne veut pas être question le peine de
mort pour celui qui fait un braquage
simple tout le monde le sait dans les
cours d'assises
cela concerne exclusivement le grand
criminel le profit or là vous avez
précisément une diminution
c'est un fait et c'est d'autant plus
important que je le rappelle en 77
monsieur peyrefitte lui même prôner
l'abolition de la peine de m qu'est ce
qu'il faut actuellement les jurés
dépasse presque systématiquement les
recommandations du ministère public est
ce que vous pensez que c'est normal est
ce qu'il ya une nouvelle réforme
apportées au système des jurés et alors
sur ce point je crois qu'à deux
observations rapide affaire de rien en
ce qui concerne la cause de cette
réaction je les ai expliqué c'est parce
que on les entretient dans un climat
général d'insécurité 2
il ya quelque chose de plus utile qui
pourrait être fait depuis très longtemps
je pense qu'avant le début de chaque
session des six les jurés qui arrivent
pour avoir les plus responsabilités les
plus lourdes qu'on puisse avoir devrait
se voir renseigné par le président
l'avocat général l'avocat au cours d'un
séminaire d'initiation à ce qui est à la
fois la responsabilité qui va être la
leur la façon dont les choses vont se
dérouler et les données actuelles de la
criminalité qu'il se renseigne qu ils
viennent là informer autrement pour le
fait c'est à dire par le récit des faits
divers comment les moins de sensibilité
et plus de connaissances la chose allait
le proposer officiellement vous allez
essayer de faire quelque chose pour que
le soin d'attacher jamais cessé de le
demander j'aurai toute occasion le
plaisir de le faire je le dis encore une
fois quand on assume de telles
responsabilités la moindre des choses
est d'initier ce qu'ils auront à les
assumer à ce que seront ces difficiles
aux fonctions je vous remercie mes bras